président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre
le public présent dans cet hémicycle ne
peut ni applaudir ni conspué les
orateurs la raison est simple les élus
ne légifère pas sous la menace
c'est un principe essentiel dans une
démocratie
depuis le vote par cette assemblée d'une
loi interdisant le port de signes
religieux lors des sorties scolaires
nombreux sont les sénateurs qui comme
moi ont reçu des mails menaçants allant
jusqu'à espérer notre mort la liste des
cent soixante trois sénateurs ayant voté
cette loi qualifiée par certains et je
cite de scélérate et jeté en pâture
le groupe facebook par le même de
sénateurs nazis et il invite ses membres
à communiquer les lieux de résidence et
les photos de parlementaires qui ont
voté ce texte les intimidations sont
explicites
notre collègue jacqueline eustache
brinio auteurs de la ppl qui mène un
combat primordial pour la laïcité a été
contrainte face à la violence des
attaques reçu de se constituer partie
civile
je tiens à lui apporter tout mon soutien
un texte démocratiquement votée par une
assemblée des parlementaires traque est
menacée et monsieur le ministre on ne
vous a pas entendu on ne vous a pas
entendu dénoncer ce qui constitue une
atteinte grave à l'exercice d'une
démocratie sereine pourquoi ce silence
pourquoi votre question le ministre de
l'intérieur à ce titre quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour mettre fin à
ses tentatives d'intimidation est devant
nous nous en inquiéter je vous remets